[Musique]
non non
dans mes nuits sans sommeil
mes désirs qui s'éveille je te sens tu
sais plus ah non soit le retrouver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tiens
dont acte
j'ai eu
[Musique]
vous
t
[Musique]
j'aimerais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
à son sommet mais disent ils se
réveillent
je creuse
[Applaudissements]
je compris
robien mois
et même si on est impuissant
barret
[Musique]
j'ai tout oublié
je cherchais
je les plains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je dois je faire
mon dieu
pour notre cas
[Musique]
mon rêve
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
kabyle ou cinq contrats fermes et bravo
bravo bravo vraiment bravo c est parce
qu elle est jolie elle et que tu adores
camino vraiment je suis très content que
tu sois là et je suis fan
c'était avec toi à fond dans danse avec
les stars si de m'insulter motus je vais
te faut dire qu'avec toi à fond demain
et ça c'est qui qui fait ça il a foi en
la taille et la forme bataille et veut
figure soit quaïda font que pour son
anniversaire
ouais je t'ai j'étais pris une combi non
[Applaudissements]
y a pas que ça ah ouais y'a pas que ça
il ya un autre cadeau dans tes artistes
préférés
donc j'ai fait jouer mes relations et je
te lis en exclu bon c'est vrai c'est ça
c'est ça c'est la conscience et la
conduite sereine que toi lahore à l'est
du coup je te donne un petit défi moi
j'espère que si si je reviens vous voir
pas fait pour la sortie de l'album est
vite avec plaisir j'suis là mes travaux
pour présenter je te grandement avons
présenté les attends je tiens ça oh là
là non il sort pas tout de suite en plus
de ces noms il devrait être là vraiment
s et michel sardou
[Musique]
encore sorti transports michel et toi tu
as un amour mérite revient surtout je
pourrais pas alors la combi mois 6 mai
la même combat que doit prendre pour du
papier alu mais c'est sûr à tanger
asilah même alors tu sais quoi en or
même et c est ça me sais que ça peut mal
et cette connerie va moi je suis
certaine on sait que ça peut mal et
cette connerie drac sans rigoler et et
bah tu sais quoi
il est beau là dedans moi je vous le dis
aujourd'hui
mobilité germées
danone envisage drac ballon on fait pour
des cadeaux et après la messe et jésus
ni verser enfin gros bisous et merci
d'avoir quelques merci à mr un amant et
bravo à la santé alors là ils vont tous
merci camion là pour ça merci ma kamilou
d'amour merci shea mercier quel bonheur
quel bonheur callebaut ne démarre bien
[Applaudissements]